so much brian yeah everyone just wants
normalcy don't we thousands of
california parents fighting back against
the school vaccine mandate by staging
these massive walkouts across the state
our next guest is a mother of three
california students who kept her kids
home from school yesterday there's their
beautiful picture lindsey bingham joins
us now with her message to state leaders
good morning lindsay
good morning good morning why did you
keep your kids home yesterday
my kids stayed home yesterday for
several several reasons we definitely
support the movement
to send a statement to our government
officials that
they are overreaching
they're encroaching our parent rights
and encroaching on the rights of
educators and staff with these mandates
well i know like if a big company if
people um if they demonstrate and they
don't go to work the company loses money
like southwest will have to cancel
flights that kind of thing but in your
situation what's the impact there will
the school board members listen
um you know it'll be interesting to find
out the school board and the district
where i'm located it's it's taking quite
a bit for them to listen to parents
and i know that you know movements like
the ones that happened yesterday there's
a lot of
logistics that go into it i know that
there are a lot of people that supported
the walkout and there was just as many
people that wanted to support but they
fear retaliation
or you know they feel a sense of
dedication to their teachers and so
you know they didn't participate but i
know that we have a lot of students that
did not show up yesterday we have some
staff that did not show up yesterday
and i think it's just you know one of
those one of the disruptions that needs
to to happen and maybe continue to
happen um until we get a voice well i
know that you're an expert in the health
care industry you're a nurse your
husband's a firefighter these are both
critical to your community you're not
anti-vaxxed right
absolutely not i think that's probably
um an important thing to understand and
i think the majority of the people that
i know that participated yesterday
contrary to the perception that's out
there are not anti-vaxx my kids are
vaccinated and you know with several
different vaccines
and um but not like every parent
hopefully
not with covered vaccines no
and we actually my kids and i had kovit
over the summer
but i was going to say you know like
every parent out there for the last 18
years i've been making decisions on
medical decisions and safety decisions
for my children based on pros versus
cons risk versus benefit
and i think
that a lot of us parents you know the
unknown with the vaccine
you know we're seeing some some
some pediatric populations that are
having immediate responses to the
vaccine that are not favorable
um but we're also
the unknown for the future is enough for
some of us to say you know we're not
comfortable doing this and we should be
able to have that right that's right all
right thank you so much lindsay keep us
posted